The Joe Rogan experience.
Different things mean this is not news.
Different things mean different things to different people.
And if you're using it in one context doesn't mean other contexts aren't
legitimate.
That's how art and images work.
Yeah.
I mean that's almost like what happened with the guy in Montana.
Right?
So when he takes his work and then turns into Nazi stuff and then all the sudden
he becomes a nod.
Right.
And that's what they do with it.
With pepe the frog.
Cause that guy who may area,
oh he's so upset.
I know.
Cause he know what they did to him log.
Do you know what they did to him?
He had a cartoon where he killed peppy.
So all the trolls are like,
oh that's interesting.
So they took all his other characters and made them full blow Nazis.
So Heinrich,
who's the wall,
instead of having reflections in a sunglasses had the SS,
they're like,
oh you want to,
you want to throw it out,
we'll throw it down,
asshole.
And that's what ended up happening to him.
Wolf has a Nazi name already now they gave him the last name.
It's like Hendrix,
something else,
but that name,
I'll tell you what they know.
Oh my God.
I know.
No,
no.
They're not seeing,
what do they call it?
That's a Nazi wolf.
Sounds like a Nazi.
Well,
maybe they,
what was the,
that's hilarious.
He thought he could just kill it off.
That's like d platforming.
He thought he was going to d platform.
Pepe.
Let's also like,
let's suppose I decided to kill off Paul Bunyan put the fuck how I can,
what does that mean?
This doesn't mean anything.
Like the idea that he's going to kill it off and they're going to say,
oh,
Whoa,
oh no.
His name was originally land wolf,
so they said,
oh,
his first name is Heinrich land.
Wolf and Eagle pull it up and the glasses,
well,
maybe we shouldn't have that sense of the imagery here,
but man wolf as opposed to what's sky wars?
Fuck does that mean,
the funny thing is about pepe?
It was,
it was always so bland and the lame,
well,
I think for,
it was adopted as a meme.
Like when you see like feels bad man,
right?
Like it was like,
Whoa,
this is so low.
Blood sugar bothers me.
But it's also the idea of,
you're saying that because Nazis are using it,
you can't use it as feels bad man.
Like right.
If you're giving the okay symbol and they're using this way,
you can't say,
oh,
that's okay.
That's make any sense.
Yeah.
You can't say something to me.
I go,
okay,
my mouse if I do that.
That's white supremacy.
Yeah,
no.
Everybody.
For years I had a whole series on my Instagram page of people doing the okay
sign.
Of course,
including me back when I had earrings,
there's radio days,
bill Cosby doing the okay,
symbol is fucking,
come on man.
You guys know this is not,
that's not what this is.
Just because people are using it and saying it is,
and they were investigating.
People are investigating people.
There was a guy who was on television,
they blurt it out.
Yeah,
and he,
they bind blurted out in Assembler.
And the other thing is we're at a point now where it's more easy to give the
finger to someone than to say,
okay,
yeah,
you blur the finger out.
Nobody cares.
But if you do that,
like,
oh,
what is he doing?
He's touching his fingers.
You can't even do like you're holding a joint cause that's like a white power
joint.
Like if you're like doing that like a roach,
that's bad.
That's bad.
How do you do you have to use a roach clip?
It's a ploy by the roach clip industry.
It's like we don't want to train in a way
that we're going to have to change our training to try to make up because all
the damage we've done.
Let's try to avoid the damage for the beginning.
It's already too late for me.
I got seven,
you know,
I got six broken ankles.
Seasons got broken,
arches broken.
What the hell did you just do?
Your ankle was like,
what's been broke six,
six or seven times broke the arch,
broke all the messages from surfing all different motorbike surfing,
snowboarding because you mess up your hip.
Uh,
probably cause my broke walking on a broken ankle for uh,
all those years that cause each time I broke it I have five or six different
breaks and then I would keep going.
So I would keep walking on it and,
but I'd means I had to carry the load on my right hip.
So I think I just wore the cartilage out from offsetting and carrying the load
of the broken Lake Jesus.
So that was,
but so I mean it's so,
it wasn't like one injury where you hurt your hip.
It was just slung.
I just wore it out.
I just,
I said I lived a couple of lives with LNL is that that was only on one life hip
and I had three lives in it.
What is it like having a fake hip?
Insane,
incredible bionic.
That thing's not even in my,
in my,
in my brain.
Not even how so it doesn't,
I just,
I don't ever even bring it into consciousness.
It's,
it's slicker.
It's like a Mercedes Benz ball joint.
I mean it's absolutely perfect.
Wow.
It's a,
and you know,
I mean I've had ACL,
had some knee stuff before that was harder to recover from them.
The hip,
the hip was,
I just felt like I got kicked by a horse for a couple months and then after that
it was like no brainer.
Jump off a cliff,
go stand up,
paddle,
run.
I mean not I tell you to not do certain things.
Nope.
Really?
You could like,
you could just start,
he don't do anything you should do with your real one.
Really.
That's going to do anything you shouldn't do with your real one.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That was the only thing.
I mean,
the guy,
the doctor Penn Nunberg who did mine,
he did it to a contortionist,
I guess some contortionist had some blown hips and he'd get it too.
And the girl is still performing and stuff.
So I don't,
I think it's,
I mean the stuff is,
the technology is amazing.
And the thing that I,
the thing that I would consider if I ever had to do it again is that the atrophy
from the,
the,
the initial problem is harder to recover from.
Then you just go in and get in the new one.
And I think when people push it,
you know,
they used to try to push that stuff because they want to wait for the technology
got better and they only last 15 years and all that stuff.
Um,
but the atrophy that you try to recover from,
it was harder to recover from than if you would've gone in and gotten it done
when you need,
when,
as soon as you needed to have it.
So the one you have now,
you have to get it swapped out every 15 years.
No,
no,
no.
But,
but in the back in the early days,
well they,
they,
they don't know how long this new stuff last.
They had some,
they had some material that that wore out after like,
cause there's a,
uh,
like a,
some kind of polyurethane,
some kind of psych outer layer.
Well like a cart lit like a,
like a manmade cartilage between the ball joint in the socket.
And so that stuff wore out in the past.
But those,
yeah.
And they had this new stuff that,
that has been in for 10 years and a lot of people are ready and they've seen
zero where on it.
So you don't know.
It could be 30,
could be,
you know,
could be 10.
I mean I I was actually,
uh,
I stayed conscious in,
in,
I was able to stay awake for my hip surgery cause I didn't want to have to
recover from the,
from the uh,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
Take people a month to get the anesthesia out of their system.
Really?
Oh yeah.
To try to get the anesthesia.
Anesthesia is controlled death.
They're just put you right to the edge of dying and keep you alive.
I mean,
anesthesia,
some hard stuff on your system to get that stuff out of your organs.
You've got to do like a full detox cleanse.
It's not dislike.
Oh yeah.
Anesthesia,
you know,
a sicario that when we sit card.
Okay.
Yeah.
Those people are looking at that movie.
A lot of the followers,
just suspicious of that,
of an ACL total.
Having an MP five,
I was the only Mexican rockin and MP five submachine gun down there.
Right.
So that's like,
is that,
you know,
what did you think of those movies?
Oh,
horrible.
Horrible,
unrealistic.
You know,
they should,
hey,
if somebody doesn't hire me,
I'll do it for free just to,
you know,
I'll consult for free on that and I'll make it look a little bit more closer to
what it is.
Uh,
but it's,
uh,
the main thing is how,
how w everybody saw that movie and that's how they would,
you know,
that's,
that's the reality.
You know,
how fiction is kind of a basis where reality,
so sicario two comes out and it's basically the United States declaring the
cartels a terrorist organization.
You know,
and I saw that and I was like,
hmm.
Usually fiction kind of pre kind of has a,
uh,
a way of influencing reality further on the line.
You know that a Denzel Washington movie called siege where the budget terrorist
attack in New York and then militarized New York and that's kind of like a
president for nine 11.
So you'd see sicario too.
And then,
you know,
we're gonna terrorist prompt now says they're going to thinking about declaring
the cartels as a terrorist organization.
That's pretty interesting.
Uh,
mainly because realistically Mexico has been calling them terrorists forever.
What did you think about that,
about Trump doing that?
Do you think that that actually is something that can happen,
uh,
if,
if you're going to militarize efforts against it and not just considered as a
law enforcement type situation,
I think people should be afraid down there if you do go that route.
Uh,
but just realize that's going to be open warfare,
not in a foreign country,
across the ocean.
It's going to be right next to your border.
Yeah.
Where people can walk across yes.
Or make things happen now in there that will affect you up here in a very real
way,
you know?
And it'll get ugly before it gets better.
Uh,
you know,
I,
hopefully it doesn't,
you know,
but that's,
if that doesn't happen,
if they don't treat it as a terrorist organization and try to have some sort of
impact on it,
what could be done?
I mean,
I think,
I think culturally they're trying to get us ready for that,
you know?
I don't know.
I mean,
I think that's what's happening.
You see a lot of the cross,
you know,
borders a US military assets training,
uh,
Mexican marines down there and having an open relationship with them.
You see that and that pushes to maybe,
you know,
preparing for something,
I think that preparing for something,
you know,
what,
what could that be?
I don't know.
So the,
what we get about it publicly is just a small sliver of the actual conversations
that are being had.
Yeah.
And also there's a lot of,
you know,
misdirection and there's a lot of misdirection.
I that I'm personally,
yeah,
the first bit we did was an accident.
It Cheech got logged outside the mixed own room.
No,
we were [inaudible] you know,
the old Charlie Chapman studio and it was little courtyard that where the sun
was beating down was like noon and it was hot and teaches a method actor and he
had it put on all the costumes,
you know,
they can get into character.
So he's got all these costumes Ziney knocks on the door and I was working the
tape recorder and when he knocked out,
I looked up at the door and I didn't see if the needle moved or not.
And so when he knocked it didn't answer and then you knocked again.
And I saw the needle moved and so I said,
who is it?
And I was supposed to just open the door and let him in.
And so there was a pause.
It's a meme there.
It's me.
Let me in.
Come on man.
So then there's that where Dave's not here came from it.
So I waited.
Then he knocked again in a long pause.
The pause.
Who is it?
And he's getting,
man,
come on,
man.
It's me.
I think the cops saw me.
You come on openness,
you know,
they went into character then.
Then are just,
wait,
wait.
It's way for me to open the door.
Then he knocked again and then finally goes,
it's me,
Dave,
man,
Dave.
I said,
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
Dave's not here.
He blew it,
kicking the doors,
screaming,
opened the door.
You're almost punched me.
And,
but I said,
listen,
listen.
We played it back and
then Lou heard it.
We recorded it.
Not as funny,
but we recorded it and next day it was all over America.
Cheech and Chong was born.
Yeah.
Then you're like,
no,
I don't.
I don't really want this.
Do you see Gaffigan and Neil and Neil Brennan?
No.
Dope.
No Way.
Gaffigan lit Neal Brennan on fire.
Shit.
On his embers.
No.
For what?
Neil started it.
Why he'll start it.
I'm going to,
I'm going to send it to Jamie.
I'm so in my sober October text message
group and listen,
I love Neil
when someone gets roasted,
so I'm going to gets roasted Kanban and it's even better because he started it.
He started for no reason.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He tried to be snarky here.
Jamie,
I'm sending this to you right now.
Jim Gaffigan is a mama.
I'm a monster.
Fantastic.
In Transylvania three you're buzzing.
Oh,
amazing.
I saw that and was he was van Helsing.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
Great.
I love those movies.
They're fun.
I love when my son gets into that stuff.
Just fucking animation today is so incredible.
I find myself sitting there watching the animation going,
this is a mate that's shading and the just the detail of it,
he can get into it where it's,
even if it's meant for kids.
As a parent,
I'm good man.
You Watch the despicable me's?
Oh yeah,
great.
Great frees up.
All three of them are great,
but I love part three with the 80 soundtrack.
It's not the creator from a South Park.
And isn't there another one with just the fucking yellow dudes?
The minions.
That's good too.
Yeah,
I saw that one little long towards the end.
It gets a little weird when they get to London,
but very good.
Yeah,
they're good man.
It's so funny when you,
so this is the text,
Brennan Service.
So,
uh,
what happens is,
Gaffigan puts up a thing saying,
hey,
why are you looking at your phone?
You could be watching my Netflix special.
I made them all for you.
And he says,
Neil says,
which one has the joke about food?
You say like a food and then you talk about it.
And I'd be over here dying.
And then Gavigan says Neil,
it's a special where I have three microphones.
One microphone is for jokes.
I pretend I can't remember that I read off a card.
One Mike is for emotional manipulation of the audience.
And one microphone is for mentioning the Chappelle show and celebrity friends.
Boom.
That's like oh core.
That's like one of those bombs that goes off in the distance.
You do see it.
And we're just like this with got a little frisky.
Got a little frisky.
Okay.